deadly gun violence is surging in
Chicago once again police say at least
57 people were shot since Friday evening
during one of the most violent weekend's
on record at least eleven were killed
there were 25 victims from five
shootings during one particularly
aggressive two-and-a-half hour period
Dean Reynolds is outside Chicago Police
Headquarters Dean good morning good
morning the shootings this weekend come
as police here point to progress against
gun violence but some community leaders
say it's not nearly enough and are
calling for the police superintendent
and the mayor to step down just after
midnight Sunday on Chicago's West Side
two men shot at a crowd during a block
party four people were hit including a
13-year old boy at another scene eight
people were shot outside an apartment
complex many of the victims are
teenagers in the Englewood neighborhood
stray bullets hit two men working on a
pool deck of a home one of the victims
ran inside to call 911 was actually
trying to help the other guy the caller
survived his coworker did not Chicago
police say over a 24 hour period 34
people were shot and five died the
youngest survivor is an 11 year old shot
in the leg Chicago police say everyone
has to be held accountable not just law
enforcement we need more help from our
judicial system we need more help from
our federal partners and we're getting
it just before the chaotic weekend more
than 200 demonstrators marched Thursday
at an anti violence
blue on black violence black on black
violence wrestling all the violence stop
it
some want the resignations of the city's
police superintendent Eddie Johnson and
Mayor Rahm Emanuel on Sunday police
pointed out that despite the weekend
violence murders in the city are down
25% so far this year shootings are down
more than 30% we can never measure what
we prevent what we can see is less
victims while the numbers are down one
of the protest organizers from last week
says that they may next try to disrupt
operations at O'Hare International
Airport to drive home the point that
more needs to be done
Gail all right Dean thank you very much